[Music]  I'm Charlie Watson I'm 18  today actually is the beetle for sale  Fury's kid happy birthday  [Music]  what are you  so you have no idea where he came from  no idea  [Applause]  well here's the deal people can be  terrible about things they don't  understand from now on only person you  can show yourself around is me oh good  now I'm good thanks  there's a war raging on our planet  if this criminal isn't found that war  may find its way sir anyone that can  help you in the family  Oh  they're calling an army  I've seen firsthand these things really  are  bumblebee there is only one way to end  this war you must protect earth and its  people  this is how we stop them  you've cut me  and I'm not going anywhere  [Music]  you